i started by asking jared kushner about
the start of his new book where he talks
about his father and the fact that he
was incarcerated and i asked him what
impact that had on a young jared kushner
my father is an amazing person he was a
very successful businessman he still is
and i made a mistake there was a family
feud and he did something
maybe an overreaction and he
went to prison for a year for me it was
a very hard experience and i thought my
life had a plan i knew it was set but
then
in a minute everything was shattered and
so i write in the book how i i really
had a turning point where i said i could
be angry at the prosecutor i'd be angry
at the people my father was fighting
with i could be angry at my father
but i didn't think that would be
productive and instead i put all of my
focus on trying to be productive for his
company for him for my family and i
think that really changed my mentality
in life which is when something bad
happens i don't spend my time being
angry about it i spend my time focusing
on how do you fix it and how do you move
forward you say it was a bad mistake by
your father um
2016 let me take you there now if i can
you talked about um the president being
prepared to be president you didn't i
mean he was one of the few people that
expected him to win in 2016. i think
it's it's fair to say that how central
were you
in the in the subsequent four years of
the trump administration yeah so in the
campaign it was really him and his kids
right so anyone who had experience who
wanted to work on the campaign for most
part was told if you work for donald
trump you'll never get a job in
washington again so it was a very
renegade campaign i write a lot in the
book about how we did things differently
whether it was building a social media
platform
and using facebook and facebook wrote
that it was the best advertising
campaign ever
conducted on facebook not just for
politics but for anything and so we did
a lot of very untraditional things we
did it well
and ultimately that won him the white
house and so uh when president did you
expect it then uh i didn't
we weren't we were prepared in the
campaign for goal line plus an inch
right in the sense that we were thinking
about
uh how do we get there and do everything
we can to make it possible we didn't
think it wasn't possible but we weren't
spending time thinking about what it
would be like if he won and then you
know on election night there were
different models again everyone the
media predicted he would lose
we saw that that it was going our way
and then we had to figure out what came
next okay let's do a deep dive into the
memoir if we may um let's start with um
the 3rd of november 2020 was that
election won by president biden or
president trump
uh president biden is the president
right now so there was a transfer of
power
um i think it was a very sloppy election
i think it's caused a lot of people in
our country to look at how our elections
are conducted you know during covid
they changed a lot of the rules which
gave a lot of people
a lot of concerns with how our elections
are conducted but the hope is is that
you know in in the next elections which
are coming up you know we'll have much
uh cleaner elections and it'll give
people a lot more confidence in terms of
in terms of what the outcome is yeah but
some still say it was stolen by the
democrats what do you think
i think they changed a lot of rules at
the last minute use covet as a pretense
to
uh to uh to
to to fight the election and i think
again even now you're seeing news that's
coming out with the fbi how they may
have gotten involved politically again
in 2020 uh to to not allow certain news
out so i think there's a lot of things
that happen that uh that give people a
lot of cause for concern so you think it
was stolen uh what i think is that joe
biden is the president right now and i
think he's been an absolutely awful
president i think we have you know a war
in russia we have out of uh out of
control uh inflation happening but if i
could just take you to the third of
november do you think that it was stolen
by the democrats yeah again i'm not
going to play the game that the media is
trying to do of putting people no no i
mean i'm i'm from the uk i don't know as
an outsider i'm just asking for
clarification from you you were right
there you were at the president's side
throughout those four years do you think
uh having been by his side that um
looking at what happened on the election
night it was stolen by the democrats
yeah so so again i'm not going to play
the game that the media is trying to
play i've made my position very clear i
think it was a very sloppy election in
terms of how it was conducted and i
think that joe biden's the president i
think that's been a disaster for our
country and for the world
um okay let me just quote a couple of
things to you seven in ten people say
biden was legitimately elected according
to the washington post
trump's own attorney general bill barr
said we have not seen fraud on the scale
that could have affected a different
outcome in the election the associated
press saying there were fewer than 500
cases of voter fraud so why are they all
wrong
i'm not saying they're wrong or right
but what i will say again if you go into
my book you go through
uh 2016 right president trump wins the
election and then you have the
washington post the ap all the sources
you just cited basically covering for
two years hyperventilating that he
colluded with russia and it was an
illegitimate election right so
again one thing i learned in in my life
is you have to find your own truths you
have to look at the details and the
facts yourself and i think that that's
why i thought it was very important to
write this book right the trump
administration had
i think some incredible successes when
you think about
historic trade deals historic peace
deals
unemployment was at a low inflation was
low wages were rising in america we were
very strong we had a peaceful world
and those things didn't happen by
accident but again you constantly had a
lot of those same media sources
you cite making accusations about the
administration that turned out not to be
true got it
republicans some right-wing republicans
continuing to challenge the result you
decided that the best place for you to
be was in the middle east with the
abraham accords tell us about that
so the abraham accords was the biggest
piece deal in the middle east maybe in
the last 50 years and what happened
there was we got israel and the arab
countries to start working together
to change the arab-israeli conflict
which i go through the history of it in
the book i tried to you know short
that it's not again i tried not to make
this an academic read but basically what
we did is we we got um
israel and the arab countries to start
working together to to break barriers
the conventional thinking in washington
before president trump came was that
you'll never have peace between the
israelis and the arabs until you make
peace with the palestinians that's what
john kerry said that's what all the
experts said before me
when i came in i go through my process
about how i explored the different
topics i spent my first year listening
to a lot of people who'd worked on the
file who were in the region leaders
there i take people into those
discussions and i kind of found my own
truth and i thought that maybe the
conventional wisdom was wrong and then
for three years we were attacked for
doing it the wrong way not like the
excerpts of experts before me and
ultimately we made that breakthrough
which turned out to be a tremendous uh
relief of tension i mean you brought a
lot of people together that otherwise
potentially would not and when people
were walking away you made the phone
call you say in the book and brought
them back to the negotiating table how
comfortable were you
being in the presence of the de facto
leader of saudi arabia very comfortable
some people have issues about the murder
of jamal khashoggi and his involvement
in that did that play on your mind at
all uh that was obviously a significant
uh consideration i i write about in the
book it was a it was an episode but
there were a lot of
yeah i write about the interactions we
had on it but look our job was to
represent america's interests in the
region and if you look at the biggest
issue we had in 2016 isis had caliphate
the size of ohio they were beheading
journalists they were killing christians
and i write about the debates that we
had in the white house about going to
saudi arabia initially because people
thought that they wouldn't change their
ways there was a lot of uh tolerance or
even encouragement of islamic extremism
and and the some of the the clerics who
were uh going into the churches
radicalizing the youth and the work that
the crown prince and his father
obviously king salman have done to
clean out the mosques try to get rid of
some of these bad elements and to fight
against islamic extremism have
dramatically shifted the world and have
made us all a lot safer and you have a
good lead a relationship rather i should
say still with mohammed bin salman and
you set up affinity partners receiving
two billion dollars i think from the
saudi sovereign wealth fund the funds
top advisors described it as
unsatisfactory in all aspects was it
your personal relationship with uh bin
salman that actually got that deal over
the line uh i ultimately they made a
decision to invest and again i was very
pleased that they were allowing us to
invest in israeli companies to further
the work that we made in the middle east
but again what what i believed and i was
not making uh secrets of this when i was
in government is that business can be a
great force to bring people together
right and then you know with the abraham
accords which we got done the last six
months of the administration we finally
opened up the channels and i write about
how we got phone calls between the
countries we had to establish banking
relationships between the countries
people can travel flights you know we
wanted muslims to be able to go to
israel and visit the mosque and so the
more you can create business interaction
between israelis and arabs i believe
what that does is it creates a
constituency for peace in the region
whereas previously there was blockage
and so the fact that they were willing
to support that endeavor by investing in
this business is something i'm very very
proud of yeah to that end do you think
mbs could expect support from any future
trump administration i think it will
always be based on the policies i think
the media always tries to yes perhaps no
i i think it's going to be policy by
policy considerate you know the media
always tries to say you're in one camp
or another and what i try to show in the
book is that we were incredibly nuanced
in the policies bad guys you know
no again i sometimes you deserve it and
sometimes maybe not but but what i find
is that if you go through the trump
administration and again i think that
you'll see there's a lot of very
rational policies that were pursued and
i think that that gets lost sometimes in
the hyperventilation or the
uh or the sensationalism of the media
and so again like it's not an accident
that the biggest trade deals got done we
had peace deals we had a great economy
there were no wars in four years no new
wars and and you know again even when
the pandemic came the vaccine was
developed in 10 months which none of the
experts thought could happen we got the
bureaucrats out of the way we brought in
the private sector and the military and
the lancet said that that saved over 20
million lives so so what i would just
say is that
again i wrote this book because number
one is i want to encourage people from
the private sector to go into washington
to go into politics i think that's very
important we shouldn't have the career
political class but i also think that
people who want to know what was really
happening inside a very consequential
time were so much got done we should
read the book 6th of january
recollection of the events that day so i
was on a plane back that day again i
think that nobody in the white house
thought there would be
violence as far as i was
aware
[Applause]
and obviously what happened was terrible
seeing people storm i got back
i obviously you know ended up getting to
the white house after a statement i put
out and then after that we worked
continuously to try to make sure there
was a peaceful transfer of power okay so
talk me through events on the day
very simple i testified to the gen 6
committee voluntarily when they called
landed in a plane
service told me to go to the home
instead of to the office which i was
happy to do i worked for about 72 hours
straight you know getting this deal done
that i was just telling you about uh
get home back jump to a shower get a
call from kevin mccarthy saying we got a
real problem here at the capitol
anything you do to help would be
appreciated so obviously put a suit on
run to the white house at that point a
statement had been out um and uh you
know and you know there was nothing more
that seemed that could be done so we put
our focus on the next day how do we make
sure messaging gets tighter and how do
we make sure we're doing everything and
in in the month leading up to that i've
been working with jake sullivan on
transitioning all the middle east files
he was up to speed on the next day the
6th of january if i may um
what did you say to the president i saw
him after it was done
so okay so you didn't see him at all
that day i saw him after it was done
he'd gone up okay um
apparently he said and perhaps you can
clarify this for me he was very agitated
and he said that he wanted to lead his
people and a former white house aide
testified that he tried to grab the
steering wheel of a car in order to go
up to the capital is that what happened
i i like i said i wasn't there but i
think that that that uh that testimony
has been heavily refuted by the secret
services
yeah but but but again i i think what i
would say is again the media spends all
of its time on sensationalism and you
have an account of somebody you know
and i'm trying to tell you there was a
that account has been you know heavily
disputed by the secret service agents
but you still want to bring up that
account instead of going through you for
clarification whether you were there you
weren't there i wasn't there that day
okay how concerned were you given that
you were such a you know a high-profile
member of the team how concerned were
you about the safety of vice president
pence
[Music]
like i said at the time i wasn't aware
of the details of what was going on but
i was concerned for the safety of
everybody obviously okay it's just again
um i actually was also uh not working at
the time but apparently there was uh
some suggestions that is his at some
point his life was was in danger that's
not something that that you were aware
of uh look i think the secret service
does a tremendous job i have a lot of
confidence they you know protected him
they protected the president they
protected our family and a lot of our
officials for
many years i don't know how close or how
not close it came that day
but like i said ultimately uh they
restored uh peace there uh i'll tell you
over five years uh there was over 600
trump rallies we never had any violence
never had any problems
and um and again it was unfortunate what
happened that day but again i don't
think you know the media again we've had
an interview now for 20 minutes you
spend five minutes talking about that
one day but you don't want to talk about
the days where we're getting historic
trade deals that are bringing 500 000
jobs back to the country you don't want
to talk about no no i'm just saying you
haven't asked me about a vaccine that
that saved 20 million lives you haven't
asked if you asked briefly about peace
deals you haven't again so my only thing
is like the media is obsessed with this
one day
i was actually about to move on to other
matters i wanted to talk to you about
your personal life actually if i may
because people are very interested in in
your
life with with ivanka and in the book um
you talk about how your marriage almost
didn't happen
tell my viewers why that was
so
we
met each other in new york i go through
this uh in pretty good detail and again
ivanka and i are both fairly private
people in terms of uh our life together
i always say that if i wasn't so
attracted to her she'd just be my best
friend and you know we feel very blessed
to have each other and you know the
great life we have with our children
and
and again we had different concerns we
were both coming up in in new york at
the time we were in different businesses
but
but we had concerns about religion some
concerns about how we wanted to live our
lives but ultimately our love was very
strong and we found ways to to work
through a lot of those issues which i
think you know again a lot of people you
know split i don't know i hope our
marriage will make it forever it's a
very strong marriage but i think working
through a lot of those issues early gave
us a really strong foundation to build
our relationship on and it was uh billy
joel who got you back together with your
uptown girl is that right
he was there that weekend but it was
really uh we were there together wendy
murdock did a great job of getting us in
a situation where we were together and i
think when we were all on a boat in the
south of france yeah neither of you
expected the other one to be there no we
were both kind of uh duped into being
there by a very uh a very uh
well-intended match mate okay well they
were obviously very successful
you went to see uh president trump your
future father-in-law to tell him that
you wanted to propose
and he said yes but by the time you went
to propose he'd already told him i
didn't find that out until later so i go
through the the proposal in the book and
actually i took my wife to a broadway
show that night
and uh broadway shows always start on
time like clockwork for whatever reason
that one was delayed
my brother was in my apartment on astor
place you know with candles and bros and
i was just nervous that the whole place
would burn down and and so we got there
i was very very nervous but luckily she
said yes and it's been an amazing
journey together ever since yeah um you
didn't
tell him that you had
thyroid cancer did you why not
i didn't i ultimately did tell him but i
didn't want to burden him he had
so many things on his mind again i i
it's hard to
imagine what it's like being the leader
of the free world you see the onslaught
of all the investigations the false
media attacks uh and then you have all
the responsibilities right so again
president trump carried the
responsibility of trying to get his
promises completed you know managing the
economy managing the world again he was
making peace deals we had a roaring
economy but there's just a lot on your
shoulders and so it was my problem the
doctors felt i had a good chance to deal
with it effectively so i set it up i
tried to duck out at a time but i write
a funny scene in the book where before
i'm about to disappear for a couple days
to get the surgery done i get called to
the oval office he closed the door which
he never did he was always a very you
know open uh president and he says you
know are you nervous about the surgery
and i said well
how do you know about that and he says
well i'm the president i know everything
so i later found out i think one of the
white house docs had told him and he
says you know don't worry about it we
got your back here take a couple days
off from work and uh whatever you need
from us we got you so he was very very
sweet about it and uh but i just didn't
want to burden him with it and have you
been pulling again recently you've had
further surgery yes i i recently went
for a checkup they found something that
required another surgery i went and did
it and uh thankfully that was uh
successful as well that's so i'm told so
how are you now how do you feel i feel
good yeah thank god yeah again medicine
today is incredible and uh you know i
yeah i just feel very blessed that
there's amazing doctors who do the great
work they do yeah um can i ask you about
obviously
we've talked about your faith a little
bit there um
i wonder it's a big deal in the uk i
know it's a big deal here as well and
the supreme court over attorney roe v
wade and its implications for the
abortion law how does that sit with your
faith
um so i believe in
pro-life and so i think it was a
properly decided decision and i think
that the different states will hopefully
come and you know i hope that in the
country again if there's a robust debate
about it people could get angry and try
to scream at each other or if there's a
legislative compromise that should be
reached then i think the legislators
should do what they should have been
doing for the last 50 years not relying
on a court decision and come up with a
position that hopefully is
representative of what the american
population wants okay i want to move on
to 2024 but can i just do a quick um
quick some quick fire questions jeff
sure um how do you relax
um i love working you know again i
always feel like work is a uh it's like
puzzles right so i i don't mind working
uh non-stop and then
you know now that i moved to miami for
four years i wasn't able to spend time
with my kids but i've been developing
different hobbies that i'm able to do
with them so like i started making them
breakfast every morning which i love
what do they like uh pancakes i'm very
good at in waffles they're there i've
done very well the technique uh the
technique is we have like a high protein
uh a batter you try to make sure you
whip it up pretty good but uh you know
getting it just right and i think the
secret ingredient yeah as long as you
get chocolate chips in it you know kind
of forgives any cooking sins so it's
good and then also taking the kids out
boating i've been learning how to do
that and fishing and you know a lot of
the different outdoor sports that you
can do in miami that you don't do in new
york so it's been a lot of fun your
children arabella joseph and theodore
did they know
that granddad was the leader of the free
world
they knew he was president but they knew
that he was granddad and they knew that
he had a big supply of chocolates so
anytime they they showed up at the
office they knew they could run in there
they'd get a kiss and uh and a bag of uh
hershey kisses oh fantastic arabella
recited poetry in mandarin to chinese
president xi didn't she at mar-a-lago
i want to talk about marie largo quickly
if i may um peace shattered there very
tranquil pace for the family uh peace
shattered by an fbi rage why did the
president take home toxic top secret
documents
you have to ask him uh that question but
you know what i will say is if if you
look at my book you'll see that he was
under constant attack
from the minute he came down as the
escalator and so you go through the
russia investigation they accused him of
doing they said he was treason and they
accused him of things and they leaked to
the press these sensational things and
nothing ended up being true they
impeached
top secret documents home potentially
risking the security of the united
states yeah i think that it's something
that again this seems like it's an issue
of paperwork that should have been able
to be worked out between doj and him i
don't know what he took or what he
didn't take but i think right now we're
relying on leaks to the media which is
the same thing we've seen the photograph
haven't we where it says top secret
yeah like i said i i i've seen a lot of
allegations made by the media over my
four years that turned out not to be
true so i think that this whole thing is
actually elevated okay well let me ask
you a different way then if if they were
top secret documents was it the wrong
thing to do
like i said i don't think we should
answer hypotheticals let's wait till we
know the facts and then we'll see what
the right way to go is i don't know what
was taken why it was taken and what's
been recovered and what the ramification
of that's going to be so the fact that
we've seen photographs that say top
secret document we should wait and see
whether or not they were even though
we're being told by the fbi
uh that they were
yeah like i said i go into my book the
accusations that were made of trump
uh if you could answer that question
yeah i mean first of all he was the
president states he had the highest
clearance in the world so i don't know
if like this may be a paperwork issue
this may be i i don't know like i said i
haven't been involved in the details of
it okay talk to me about 2024 would you
like to
when might he decide whether he's going
to run or not
you know nobody can speak for him have
you spoken to him about it uh he's asked
me about it i said it you know it's
tricky
uh
i'd rather not go into that but but
basically i know that he's um he's
obviously thinking about it he hates
seeing what's happening in the country
you know he had the economy running so
well he filled the hall economically
that was caused by covid he got us out
of it with the vaccine
and uh and again we had peace in in
europe peace in the world china was on
their back foot and now you have a war
with you know in ukraine with russia
never would happen again you know we was
just seeing online the the clip was
playing of trump basically at the u.n
saying that germany shouldn't be relying
on russia for their natural gas that
causes a big vulnerability and the
russian diplomats were laughing at him
and the media was laughing at him big
issue in the uk and and europe
absolutely but um when will he decide
when will he have to decide we're
heading towards the midterms aren't we
so he's going to have to decide soon uh
when he's ready yeah i i like it's not
really out there is he i'm sorry he's
not ruling it out uh like i said with
trump it's hard to rule anything out so
he's uh he's a very flexible thinker
yeah would you like to be part of a
trump administration
um
the answer is yes isn't it no the answer
is is that you know right now my mind is
is really enjoying the private sector i
think that again i don't believe that
people should be career political people
i think that it's an amazing honor to be
able to go and serve your country if he
rang up and said you know what jared i'm
going to run again and i'd like you to
be part of my administration you
couldn't say no to him yeah i think the
difference between
a next time potentially and last time is
now he has so many qualified people who
are around who are in the administration
uh
yeah but it's uh but but there's a lot
of great people now and so my hope would
be that uh that with some of those great
people they'll be able to play roles and
i'll be able to you know support them in
any way he's definitely gonna run his
name
like i said with him you never know so
it's uh he keeps it interesting all the
time jared kushner it's been a pleasure
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you for having me thank you